Hillary Clinton and Donald Trump. Donald
Trump and Hillary Clinton. Hillary Trump
and Donald Clinton. No matter how you
rearrange their names something is really
really wrong with our political system
right now. You know this to be true
whether you're a political junkie or if
you couldn't name the vice president if
your life depended on it.
Our broken system churning out
uninspiring candidates, coupled with our
broken media that often just repeats
campaign talking points, has given us two
broken candidates from two broken
parties competing in a broken election
for control of a nation going broke.
This isn't how it was supposed to be nor
is it how it has to be.
I don't particularly like Hillary
Clinton or Donald Trump. Hillary has been
involved in the political machine for
the past 30 years at various levels from
wife of a governor, to first lady, to
Senator, to Secretary of State and it's
not really clear to me if her
accomplishments outweigh her poor
decisions.
Nothing she says strikes me as real or
honest, like how she's constantly railing
against wall street while at the same time
taking at least 25 million dollars from
Wall Street this campaign cycle alone. At
a time when we're all frustrated by the
system she is the ultimate insider
trying to maintain her grip on power. Add
her willful ineptitude at best, or gross
negligence at worst with her emails,
her questionable decisions in Iraq and
Libya and the Clinton Foundation's ties
to various foreign governments, and there
is a lot of questions about her campaign.
She also constantly plays into the
social justice and oppression Olympics
which judges us all as groups rather
than individuals, and a pretty sure you
guys know how I feel about that.
As for Trump even after all these months
of campaigning I still have no real idea
what he thinks about any issue. He seems
to have a staggeringly low amount of
knowledge about basic policies or how
the government is designed to work.
Do you really think he knows the different
duties of the executive legislative and
judicial branches of government? The fact
that I can't say so for sure that he
does is extremely concerning to say least. I
also don't sense he has any sort of
moral Center other than what's good for
him at the very moment. He will say
anything, quite literally anything, to
stay in the news and we simply have no
idea how he would govern. His comments
constantly tow the line between fact
and fiction, and he seems deeply
uninterested in other opinions than his
own. While many think he'll shatter the
monster of political correctness
currently assaulting us it seems like a
tall order for someone who threatens
to ban news organizations and sue
reporters when they ask him hard
questions, or challenge his statements. So how did we possibly get to a place where
everyone I talk to is either
begrudgingly voting for one of these two
people or just won't vote at all?
How did we end up with too deeply
unpopular polarizing people who
seemingly represent the worst of us as
the only two legitimate candidates for
the highest office in the land?
It's probably time we looked in the
mirror and saw our own responsibility in
this unfolding clown show. The writing
has been on the wall for years. We watch
garbage reality shows, some of them
hosted by future presidential candidates,
we read biased listicles full of gifs
instead of actual news articles. We say
vicious things to people online that we
would never say to their faces. Our
thoughts have been reduced to six second
videos, one hundred hundred and forty character
sentences, filtered images, and mindless
snaps. We reward the Kardashians with
fame and fortune while we can't come up
with the money to take care of our
veterans. We watch news channels that are
nothing but mouthpieces for the
political parties. We shame, and slander
and de-platform people we disagree with.
We issue trigger warnings and safe spaces
instead of promoting true education and
open discussion. We ask for better
leaders but then we don't vote
on election day. We complain but we don't
get involved. When you step back and you
think about all of this it's pretty
obvious why we got left with these two
candidates. Now allow me to make the
quick case of why you should vote for
each one of these people in case you
didn't think I was going to do that. With
Hillary, you know what you're going to
get. Our system is messed up but she's
part of it and she's damn well going to
make sure that the wheels don't come off
during her watch.
She's a known quantity in that she cares
about her legacy and she doesn't want to
see the country crumble after spending
her entire life trying to get to this
very place. In short if you think things
are going ok
it makes sense to vote for Hillary. The
case for Trump is totally the reverse.
He's an unknown quantity andn the system
hates him. He's giving a voice to middle
America that is usually ignored or
mocked by the elite. He represents the
greatest threat to this social justice
fiasco infecting all levels of society.
he's used the political system and our
pathetic media against itself. In short,
if you think that things are really
messed up and we have to change it at
any cost
then it absolutely makes sense to vote
for Trump. I for one, despite everything
I've said here, think that the truth lies
somewhere in between. There is no
question that our system is screwed up
but the truth is, it's still one of the
best ones out there and despite our
flaws. Americans have freedoms which make
people all over the world envious. People
still look to America as a beacon of
light in the world. People still want to
move here, and most of us don't want to
move out.
We have an imperfect system but a system
that can and will survive these two
imperfect candidates. Some people are
voting for Hillary because they think
she's the last line of defense against
Trump who they liken to Hitler. Some
people are voting for Trump because they
think he's the only way to stop Hillary
the Manchurian candidate.
What a sad and pathetic state were in.
Hillary, a candidate saying she can fix
everything that's wrong even though it's
her team who's been in power for the
past eight years, and Trump a man who's
staggering lack of worldly knowledge
outside of his own tiny bubble is
somehow considered an asset by his
supporters. Now before I tell you who I'm
going to support and why, I want to say
one more thing.
Whoever you choose in this election, I'm
actually okay with it.
Probably the most important thing I've
been fighting for with this show is the
ability to agree to disagree. To sit
across from someone and hear their ideas
and make your own judgment call.
I don't ask that you agree with my
guests or even myself in this case. I
don't ask that you support who I support,
nor agree with my reasons for supporting
them. What I hope for, not ask for, is that
all of us whether you support Hillary or
Trump, are able to sit across from people
who support the other person. That
regardless of who someone votes for we
realize we have two candidates but one
country, and most importantly that people
are able to make different choices than
you for different reasons, and that
doesn't mean they're mean or evil or
even worse - gross and racist. I spent a
lot of time on The Rubin Report talking
about the role of government.
it's something so important, yet in our
public discourse we rarely talk about it,
even as government gets bigger and
bigger. Both the Democrat and Republican
conventions were perfect examples of
this. At the DNC, speaker after speaker
talked about how Hillary could solve all
of your problems.
I guess she's had all the answers this
whole time but just forgot to tell them
to her old pal Barack. Every speaker,
including Hillary herself, said that she
has the answers and that government
under her watch can solve everything.
The RNC wasn't very different though, for
a series of other reasons. Trump and his
speakers talked about how corrupt the
system is but their answer was that
Trump, and Trump alone could fix it.
Immigration? Well only Trump has the
answers. The economy? Only Trump could fix
it. Terrorism?
Only Trump could keep us safe. In
both cases the answer to everything was
bigger government. Your decisions, be
economic or personal, should be given to
you by the government.
This concept has been creeping on us for
a long time, and now we have two
candidates that think they are the only
ones who know how to live your life, even
better than you do.
There is simply only one way out of this
mess, and I don't think it involves
propping up a broken system or burning
it down altogether. Every election we
hear this is the most important election
in a generation, but you know at this
time it actually might be true. Despite
everything, we deserve better than this
endless battle between Republicans and
Democrats who are more concerned about
their grip on power than they are
addressing the needs of the people that
they're supposed to serve. There is only
one way to take the power away from
their monopoly over our lives. We must
from this election forward put both the
Democrats and the Republicans on notice
that they no longer have a stranglehold
on the political process in America. The
only way we can do this is to starve
them. We must starve them of our
attention, of our money, and our votes.
Their diet must begin right now.
For these reasons and some others I'll
be supporting Libertarian candidate Gary
Johnson for President the United States.
I don't think Gary is the perfect man
nor the perfect candidate, and I suspect that
he doesn't think he is either - but he's
sure better than these other two options.
As a libertarian, Gary doesn't want to
tell you who you can marry and what you
can smoke. He wants lower taxes and to
empower local, not federal government,
which in my view is always a good thing.
He wants to give the power back to the
people to control their own lives. He
wants a fair resolution to our
immigration problem, and he acknowledges that radical Islam - especially in the
form of Sharia law, is a real threat. He
wants a strong military so that we won't
have to use it, not so that we can go on
military adventures and nation build. His
blend of being fiscally conservative and
socially liberal is really
where I think most people are
ideologically but we just never get the
chance to choose it. I do have some
differences with Gary, and the
Libertarian Party in and of itself is a
total mess, but i think he best
represents the ideals I would want in a
president.
Sometimes you have to stand on principle
even when you know the result will be a
short-term loss. Now before you guys tell
me I'm throwing my vote away let me lay
out a plan here. I think that if you've
listened this far you acknowledge that we
do have a problem here.
Well the only way we're ever going to
solve this problem is by getting more
voices heard, not less. If Gary gets to
fifteen percent in an average of national
polls then they have to put him in the
Presidential Debates. Why not have at
least one debate with another voice. At the
absolute bare minimum we deserve to hear
one different point of view now more
than ever. I don't need a president to be
my savior, but maybe having an
alternative to the two-party strangle hold
on American politics is actually what
can save us. The polling maybe antiquated
and many only use landlines instead of
cell phones, but I think if there was
enough public support to get Gary to
fifteen percent they would have to put
him in.
I don't think Gary's even a particularly
good debater but how about once, just
once, for the first time since Ross Perot in
1992 we get a third person on that
debate stage. From now until the debates
Gary Johnson has my support. While I
acknowledge that he will not be
president, nor do I agree with him on
everything I think he best represents
the ideals that I want to see from our
government and our president. If we're
ever going to fix this broken mess we
must start now. Let's show the Democrats
and the Republicans that they don't own
us, but they do owe us. They owe us the
chance to hear more voices because they
damn well haven't done a great job while
they've been in charge. If Gary doesn't
hit the fifteen percent threshold or
does one debate and then his support
falters I'll decide what to do at that
time.
Regardless, I think that the classical
liberal and libertarian ideals that Gary
embodies more than either of the other
two candidates can truly, and should
truly, be the future of American politics.
We need a new generation of leaders who
believe in these ideas to wake up right
now but it just isn't going to happen by
itself. So let's put the people in power
on notice and let them know that we
won't be sleeping until 2020. Instead
we're going to make sure that they know
with absolute certainty that this is
their last free ride before the rest of
us are heard.
Alright, so there you go. Simply by the
math alone I suspect that my choice with
have more people angry at me then either of the other two choices could have, but I
hope that whether you agree with me or
whether you disagree with me, that you
respect the rationale in the logic that
I've used to come to my decision. At the
end of the day one of these people will
be President and we're still all going
to be here so let's try to be better
than them, before Canada builds a wall, to
keep us all out.